[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
aurore bergé bonjour à mon cher simon
que d'être avec nous député des yvelines
présidente déléguée du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour pascal jalabert des
journaux du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on commence bien sûr par la crise
sanitaire aux bergers cette situation
tendue très tendue en ile de france et
particulièrement dans les hôpitaux vous
avez sans doute lu ce message hier des
médecins de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris
nous serons contraints de faire un tri
des patients disent qu'il est ce que le
gouvernement l'exécutif s'est trompé de
stratégie
je crois encore une fois on a toujours
eu la même stratégie qui est évidemment
la priorité sanitaire
on nous l'a parfois d'ailleurs reproché
et vous voyez bien la situation qui est
presque inextricable d'arriver à
déterminer quel est le bon choix entre à
la fois l'urgence sanitaire et donc la
santé des français
et puis les autres urgences qui sont
tout aussi importantes dans nos vies la
question psychologique on le voit bien
les le risque de saturation d'un certain
nombre de français
la question économique la question
sociale la question éducative et donc à
chaque fois on essaye d arbitrer au plus
juste mais avec toujours en tête une
priorité qui est justement de ne jamais
prendre de risques avec la santé des
français
elle c'est la région par laquelle mais
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a pris
des mesures qui sont plus coercitif ça
fait un an
ça fait un an que les français vivent
avec des restrictions au regard de leurs
libertés publiques ça fait un an que ces
décisions sont prises et qu'elles sont
difficiles à prendre et nécessaire à
prendre est nécessaire à suivre on en a
imposé des nouvelles on le voit bien
notamment nous en ile de france en terme
de restriction d'un certain nombre de
nos déplacements
je crois qu'on fait tout encore une fois
pour à la fois ralentir la progression
du virus accélérer la campagne de
vaccination mais aussi se doter de choix
qui sont supportables soutenable pour
les français donc ça veut dire vous
maintenez la stratégie et nos tribunes
dans l'eau
dans cette fois au toujours des médecins
de lestang publique hôpitaux de paris
dix en imposant aux soignants de décider
quel patient doit vivre le gouvernement
se déresponsabilise de façon ou pau
creed qu'est ce que vous aimez ya aucune
déresponsabilisation du gouvernement ou
des parlementaires puisque nous sommes
évidemment complètement solidaire sur
les décisions qui ont été prises il ya
encore une fois un arbitrage et il
suffit de discuter avec les français qui
subissent de plein fouet à la fois la
crise sanitaire qui subissent aussi les
restrictions pour voir qu'en fonction
que par de l'endroit où on parle on en a
une appréciation extrêmement différent
donc je peux comprendre
évidemment les soignants qui sont
confrontés directement et qui disent
aller plus loin dans les restrictions
qui sont imposées et puis on parle aussi
tout simplement à nos concitoyens qui
disent nous on n'est plus en état
d'arriver à supporter des décisions
nouvelles pour des raisons aussi encore
une fois psychologiques on le voit bien
on a des alertes qui sont très forts y
compris d'ailleurs d'une partie du corps
médical
les psychiatres en particulier dans
notre pays on voit bien aussi la
lourdeur d'un certain nombre de
décisions pour la jeunesse de notre pays
donc il faut qu'on arbitre
si on arrive à un point de risque qui
est trop important il a toujours dit que
le confinement c'était une décision
ultime la décision le point dernier euro
important au-delà du tri des patients
qu'est-ce que celles au point de mai ce
sera ce sera un arbitrage en fonction
justement le taux d'occupation des lits
en réanimation en fonction de l'état de
santé ans en fonction du taux
d'incidence est encore une fois on ne
vous avez bien vu qu'il y avait une
échelle dans jules les restrictions qui
était mise en place
enfin on est dans un état démocratique
imposé des restrictions sur les libertés
publiques
ça peut pas s'exercer à la légère ce
d'autant plus quand on vit déjà ce
régime de restriction depuis un an
donc c'est sa porte on ne peut pas ne
pas avoir en tête que de nouvelles
restrictions au peloton prendra pour
fermer les écoles et ce qu'il ya
d'autres mesures qui sont envisagées
mois sur les écoles parce que je sais
que c'est un évidemment un des sujets
prégnant de débat en particulier en
seine saint denis qui est l'un des
départements les plus touchés par la
crise je reste persuadé que les écoles
doivent rester ouvertes ou si longtemps
que c'est possible de le faire
c'est un choix très clair de la france
c'est une vraie singularité aussi de la
france alors que dans un certain nombre
d'autres pays les écoles ont été fermées
et on a des enfants qui pendant des mois
n'ont pas vu les salles de classe qui
sort a estimé les dégâts que ça a causé
non seulement sur l'éducation de ses
enfants mais sur l'explosion de la
pauvreté des risques psychosociaux des
violences intrafamiliales qui ont re pas
été détectée c'est enfin le vrai choix
qui a été fait qui est une vraie
singularité de la france les écoles moi
j'en suis fier
j'en suis vraiment fier et je les assume
et je reste persuadé que quand je
l'espère on pourra enfin faire le bilan
de la crise ça voudrait dire qu'elle
sera derrière nous le fait d'avoir tout
fait pour maintenir les écoles ouvertes
ce sera quelque chose qui sera mis à
notre crédit parce qu'encore une fois
c'est la manière la plus puissante de
lutter contre les inégalités dont mais à
quel prix sur le plan sanitaire mais
encore une fois on n'a jamais pris de
risque et vous avez bien vu que le
protocole il est renforcé
c'était dans les départements dits en
zone rouge 3-4 qu'ovide fermeture de
classe aujourd'hui c'est un cas de kovy
de fermeture immédiate de classe c des
tests salivaires qui sont déployés dans
les établissements scolaires donc mais
moi je reste vraiment mais intimement
persuadé que la fermeture des écoles
aurait été la pire des choses pour nos
enfants on a des enfants d'ailleurs qui
à travers le monde des enseignants qui à
travers le monde demande la réouverture
des écoles où on n'en peut plus et là
que je suis s'annonce différent
plusieurs élèves qui se retrouvent dans
plusieurs classes voire qui rétrograde
d'un niveau parce que leurs enseignants
ne sont pas là est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'on est dans un enseignement de
qualité toujours mais moi je reste
persuadé qu'on fait les enseignants font
du mieux qu'ils peuvent dans une
situation qui est complètement
exceptionnel évidemment mais est ce
qu'il vaut mieux tout faire pour
maintenir les écoles ouvertes et
permettre à nos enfants de continuer à
apprendre de continuer à avoir un des
liens sociaux des liens affectifs de
continuer tout simplement pouvoir suivre
leur scolarité dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
ou est-ce qu'on aurait dû avoir une
solution de facilité qui était dire ok
on ferme les écoles les parents se
débrouille
les enfants qui suivent maïs des vous y
arriverons tant mieux puis par contre
les enfants pour lesquels les parents ne
peuvent pas suivre parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas assumer la scolarité de
leurs enfants
et bien c'est pas dur alors très pur à
des dégâts il y aura des dégâts sociaux
il y aura des dégâts collatéraux mais on
a su manoeuvrer
dellac politiques demandent la fermeture
des écoles y compris dans l'opposition
est ce que par exemple il ne faudrait
pas avancé les vacances scolaires comme
par exemple le demande valérie pécresse
est ce que ça c'est une bonne solution
un bon compromis
mais en quoi est ce que ça permettrait
réellement de freiner la propagation du
virus
depuis des mois ce que nous disent les
scientifiques s'est coincé que le virus
se propage où il se propage dans les
réunions familiales
il se propage dans l'environnement
social qui est le vôtre vous avez moins
de brassage dans une école où justement
tout est fait pour que vous restiez
uniquement avec vos camarades de classe
en essayant d'être le plus possible en
distance yale avec des règles sanitaires
clair on le sait très bien et c'est
naturel quand vous entrez dans votre
propre domicile quand vous retrouvez
quelques copains le week-end
vous n'avez plus les mêmes règles
sanitaires qui prévalent donc si c'est
se dire on avance les vacances scolaires
mais finalement on prend le risque qui
est justement beaucoup plus de brassage
beaucoup plus de mélange
parce que c'est naturel c'est humain on
va retrouver ses amis ses proches sa
famille et on va oublier les gestes
barrière je ne suis pas certaine qu'à la
fin ce soit plus bénéfique et d'ailleurs
on a bien vu souvent que le pic équipe
des épidémies qu il était constaté quand
justement au retour de vacances elle
juste l'aurait finalement justement les
vacances arrivent et on a vu les deux
week-end dernier beaucoup de
francilienne la zone rouge allait vers
d'autres territoires
est ce que vous craignez pas qu'avec le
week-end prolongé de pâques
et puis derrière les vacances scolaires
on assiste de nouveau à cette migration
bain de zones contaminées dans un monde
dominé faut-il limiter les déplacements
les déplacements ils sont déjà limité
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas le droit de
vous rendre dans un autre département au
footy vraiment contrôler parce que que
quand on regarde il ya du monde sur les
routes y devine l1 évidemment qu'on doit
pouvoir contrôler et se fera que ça
c'est une nécessité absolue est
d'ailleurs encore une fois aujourd'hui
moi je ne suis concerné au premier chef
en ile de france dans les yvelines
vous n'avez pas le droit de vous rendre
dans un autre département à plus de 30
km sauf quand vous êtes frontaliers on
va dire d'un département parce que
parfois vous y avez votre médecin vous
pouvez faire vos courses vous emmenez
vos enfants une activité extrascolaire
mais non l'idée c'est évidemment pas
qu'on puisse partir en vacances comme si
de rien n'était
c'est des règles qui sont pas simples et
on les vit tous mais de fait on sait
qu'on n'aura pas d'autre choix est donc
évidemment il faut qu'on arrive à éviter
encore une fois toute propagation ses
vacances d'outre-tombe là où on joue
trop bas c'est malheureusement ce qui va
falloir qu'on accepte de respecter on a
la chance aussi d'avoir des territoires
qui nous permettront aussi me dépayser
différemment je sais que c'est pas
évident enfin vous savez faire et puis
j'ai pas envie d'infantiliser les gens
les gens ils savent très bien ce qu'ils
ont à faire
ils ont largement compris les règles
sanitaires je pas là pour leur rappeler
en permanence les règles qui doivent
respecter ou pas par contre je sois pour
assumer politiquement les décisions qui
ont été prises par est de freiner la
propagation du virus sont celles qui à
mon avis sont pertinentes d'un point de
vue sanitaire sont acceptables encore
une fois au regard de restriction que
les français acceptent déjà de respecter
depuis déjà un an
on va parler d'un autre sujet aurore
bergé était régionale et audrey pulvar
la candidate en ile-de-france candidate
notamment du parti socialiste qui a fait
polémique ce week-end en réagissant aux
réunions bon mixte organisé par l'unef
elle dit qu'elle ne doivent pas être
qu'elles ne doivent pas être interdite
aux blancs mais que si des personnes
blanches y viennent elles doivent se
taire qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
ces propos mais j'étais très interloqué
parce que audrey pulvar pour moi je
n'étais pas du tout justement dans ce
registre là quand je regarde l époque
elle a pu tenir mais justement cette
espèce de déliquescence d'une partie de
la gauche vers des thèses qui sont des
thèses indigéniste considérer qu'on
combat mieux le raciste le racisme en
étant dans l'antre soit celle inverse on
combat le racisme parce que justement on
accepte d'attendre une société qui est
une société ouverte qui est une société
mixte on combat pas la racisme avec des
réunions il n'y aurait d'un côté que des
blancs des réunions il y aurait que d'un
côté que des noirs et c'est là la force
justement d'une société qui d'une
république qui se veut universel c'est
qu'on accepte de porter des combats même
si on les vit pas nous mêmes dans notre
char nous est déjà arrivé et j'imagine
vous-même de défiler par exemple quand
il y a eu des appels à des
rassemblements par exemple pour
l'assassinât de mire et knoll qui avait
été suscitée par ce que juive
j'ai des filles dans ces rassemblements
je ne suis pas juive mais parce que je
suis française et donc je me sens
concernée par certains de nos
concitoyens qui parce que juif
peuvent être malheureusement encore dans
notre pays assassiné et donc c'est ça
qui doit nous concerne et j'ai défilé
pour le mariage pour tous et je ne suis
pas lesbienne mais tout simplement parce
que je me sentais concernée à l'idée que
certains des français n'est pas les
mêmes droits
tout simplement que les miens en
fonction alors elle est aussi qu'elle a
dans des réunions
lgbt sexuelle et va mais elle se tait
mais pourquoi se taire enfin c'est quoi
cette espèce de nouvelles
discriminations donc ces espèces d'entre
d'eux à dire on
il faut pas les réunions non mixtes mais
par contre si on va dans des danses et
type de réunion il faudrait qu'on se
taise ça ça n'a pas de sens c'est pas ça
la vocation d'une république qui se veut
justement universaliste encore une fois
heureusement c'est un tout le monde à
gauche n'a pas tenu les mêmes propos de
stéphane le foll les a condamnés quand
on voit que carole delga avait été mise
en cause par un mouvement xénophobe qui
est celui de l'action française qui a
essayé de s'introduire de force au sein
de la région et elle a tenu des propos
qui sont justement des propos dont
seulement évidemment pour condamner
cette intrusion qui est inacceptable
mais qui sont aussi très clair d'un
point de vue républicain allant
d'ailleurs jusqu'à déclencher les ires
de jean luc mélenchon qui lui a reproché
d'être quoi juste républicaine et
douleur partager les valeurs de la
république
moi je crois que malheureusement il ya
une partie de la gauche qui aujourd'hui
court derrière un certain nombre de
mouvements court derrière europe
ecologie les verts court derrière ces
courants de bus passion des courants de
pensée mais en cours a en tout cas des
courants idéologiques indigéniste
notamment qui ne sont pas ce qu'est
l'histoire et l'identité de notre pays
et qui je l'espère ne le seront pas
demain dans votre camp tout le monde
condamne ne condamnent pas fermement ces
propos à commencer par christophe
castaner votre président groupe lui il
parle de propos maladroits et il dit que
ce type de réunion est parfois
nécessaire
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé des propos
de la présidente dont jean christophe
castaner il a été ministre de
l'intérieur il a toujours été
extrêmement clair sur ces questions là
et je crois qu'il ya aucune ambiguïté
aussi l'ars est moins fiable en marche
coûté en tout cas il n'y a jamais eu
d'ambiguïté de notre part sur ces sujets
là la république encore une fois elle se
vit à visage découvert elle se vit de
manière universelle elle se vit dans le
partage se fait dans l'ouverture
elle se vit en mixité elle se vit pas
dans l'entretoit moi j'ai pas envie pour
soi chacun dans des camps retranchés
j'ai pas envie qu'à un moment on ne
puisse exister non pas au travers de ce
qu'on fait mais au travers de ce qu'on
serait parce qu'on serait réduit
finalement à notre condition soit
d'orientation sexuelle soit notre
couleur de peau soit notre identité
c'est pas ça
la république un dernier mot un dernier
mot là-dessus marine le pen elle a dit
que le parquet doit engager des
poursuites pour provocation à la
discrimination raciale est ce qu'il faut
aller jusque là pour vous mais moi pas
non plus accuser audrey pulvar de
racisme alors là un moment on devient
tous fous dans ce pays donc encore une
fois je condamne les propos qui ont été
les siens je pense qu'ils sont
inappropriées je pense que celle inverse
de ce qu'on doit faire pour combattre le
racisme et je pense pas non plus audrey
pulvar évidemment le soir je pense qu'il
faudrait tout ce qu'on arrive à
retrouver notre cacao c'est sujet
justement en ile de france donc il y a
une liste républicain marche modem qui
devra sans doute discuter entre les deux
tours puisque c'est une élection où la
proportion avec des alliances entre
valérie pécresse choses auraient pu le
voir qui choisiriez vous mais d'abord
moi je fais campagne avec laurent saint
martin et commence avec le modem avec
agir avec territoire de progrès vous
n'allez quand même pas commencé il va
falloir choisir mais il va falloir
choisir où il va falloir se maintenir en
fait ça dépendra tout simplement de ce
que les franciliens nous dirons à
l'issue du premier tour des régionales
donc moi je vais d'abord me battre pour
le premier tour pour porter un certain
nombre d'idées parce que on est dans une
région qui est la plus riche de france
mais qui est aussi la plus inégalitaire
de france quand on parlait des
inégalités en matière de santé notamment
en seine-saint-denis
on voit bien que la région est là aussi
elle doit avoir son mot à dire qu'on
parle des questions de mobilité
quand par les questions culturelles des
questions éducatives des questions
sociales des questions sanitaires
on ne peut pas rester encore une fois
dans ce déséquilibre là et d'ailleurs
quand on parle des enjeux de
discrimination c'est bien simple le vrai
sujet qu'on doit pouvoir combattre c'est
comment on combat efficacement et
discrimination par avec ce type de
solution en non mixité mais au contraire
en ayant une politique sociale et
éducative traque un mois c'est là dessus
que j'ai envie de me battre
un dernier mot sur les régionales on
attend dans les prochaines heures la vie
du conseil scientifique sur un éventuel
report ou pas est-ce que vous vous
opposerez un tel report moi j'attends la
décision et les recommandations du
conseil scientifique je préférerais que
ces régionales se tiennent je crois que
c'est important aussi qu'on est en cycle
démocratique et qu'on puisse tenir ses
élections
on les a légèrement décalé déjà et je
crois que c'est important je crois que
les différents présidents de région à se
sont prononcés stanislas guérini l'a
fait aussi pour la république en marge
donc je crois donc tout faire pour les
maintenir
encore une fois je
je me doute que c'est pas la priorité
absolue des français il se réveille pas
le matin en nous disant il faut
absolument tenir les élections
régionales
par contre je voudrais pas qu'on nous
reproche voilà d'avoir changé le rythme
électorale parce que l'objectif il est
pour des camions les questions
sanitaires et je voudrais pas qu'on
puisse penser qu'ils aient une
quelconque arrière pensée donc j'attends
de voir ce que propose ou ce que
préconise le conseil scientifique pour
ma part sauf encore une fois risques
sanitaires extrêmement avéré je
préfèrerais qu'elles se tiennent aux
dates prévues
on va parler de la loi climat que
l'assemblée nationale
entame aujourd'hui un début de l'examen
pour deux semaines et des milliers de
personnes qui ont défilé dans les rues
de france hier pour dénoncer le manque
d'ambition de cette loi climat qu'est ce
que vous avez entendu ce message et
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ces
personnes ont déjà j'ai vu des
manifestations se tenir qui à mon avis
respectait pas tout à fait les règles
sanitaires justement dont on me parlait
à l'instant mais oh ceci étant dit on a
une loi qui répond pour moi à des enjeux
majeurs c'est à dire comment on
s'attaque à ce qui est aujourd'hui le
plus émetteur de co2 et comment on fait
pour garantir ce qu'on appelle une
trajectoire carbone pourquoi c'est pas
par un calcul politique c'est parce
qu'en fait s'il ya une urgence c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix que
d'arriver à baisser de 40% nos émissions
de co2 d'ici 2030 on a les accords de
paris dans lesquelles nous nous sommes
fortement engagés mais on doit
maintenant tenir cette rage à l'est ce
texte va le permettre c'est pas ce que
disent les opposants c'est parce que
disait alors une quête sauter il est
l'un des éléments clés pour y parvenir
il s'ajoute à des décisions très fortes
aussi qui ont été prises en matière
environnementale depuis le début que ce
soit l'exploitation des hydrocarbures
dans d'autres pays que ce soit à la
question de la fermeture par exemple un
l'arrêt du projet notre dame des landes
ou du thé à quatre à roissy dire à
chaque fois qu'on a eu des projets dont
on estimait qu'écologiquement il n'avait
aucun sens on les a arrêtés alors que ce
sont des décisions qui territorialement
était extrêmement difficile à prendre
avant vous souvenez de la polémique sur
notre dame des landes ce n'était pas une
décision facile d'arrêter ce projet mais
on a considéré que l'écologie il est
question environnementale devait
prévaloir sur d'autres intérêts c'était
pareil avec europa city
quand une fois c'est passante d'aller
expliquer un territoire que des projets
qui étaient portées ne peuvent pas voir
le jour parce qu'on considère qu'il dise
fonctionnerait par rapport à nos enjeux
est à nous hurlaient qu'on nous entende
et barbara pompidou et la ministre de la
transition écologique dire elle même
qu'un espère que les parlementaires ont
voté des avancées f qu'elle même ne
reconnaît pas que ce texte n'est pas à
la hauteur mais elles portent les enjeux
écologiques d'un marin pompier depuis
toute sa vie politique
c'est le coeur même de ce qui est son
engagement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle est aujourd'hui ministre
en charge à 35 encore des choses à nan
ça veut dire qu'il faut en aucun cas
accepter qu'il y ait
des engagements qui serait renier vous
savez si j'avais accepté je suis
rapporteur sur une partie de ce texte on
est on l'examiné en commission d'abord
si j'avais accepté les amendements des
républicains je pense que j'aurai
supprimer un par un tous les articles de
ce projet de loi il resterait rien ils
n'ont proposé quasiment que des
amendements de suppression donc
clairement c'était pas rogner sur
l'ambition c'est est supprimée
l'ambition et puis de l'autre côté on a
une vision qui est une vision
idéologique où on nous parle de
décroissance ou delphine batho me disait
il faut supprimer le mot croissance des
manuels scolaires
enfin c'est pas parce que vous avez
supprimé le mot croissance des manuels
scolaires
vous allez mieux lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique c'est parce que
vous allez permettre par exemple
interdire la location des passoires
thermiques en 2028 c'est parce que vous
allez aussi mettre les moyens financiers
7 milliards d'euros sur la table sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments des
logements sociaux pour accompagner les
français dans la transition écologique
ça c'est non mais quel jeu vous allez
faire pour répondre à la demande de
barbara pompili qui demandent plus plus
d'avancé qu'est ce que vous allez
apporter en plus vous on a un certain
nombre d'amendements que nous on va
essayer de défendre moi parisienne sur
la question de la publicité puisque ce
sont les sujets dont je m'occupe je veux
qu'on lutte contre ce qu'on appelle en
mauvais français le greenwashing ou le
blanchiment écologique parce que je ne
veux pas qu'on puisse continuer à faire
de la publicité qui seraient mensongères
et s'est trompé les français leur rien
vous allez acheter tel produit il va
être neutre en carbone
c'est pas vrai c'est fallacieux et donc
les français qui sont attachés aux
enjeux écologiques peuvent être dupés
peuvent être trompés par ce type de
publicité par contre je veux pas en
effet interdire toute publicité
pourquoi parce que c'est aussi l'enjeu
du financement de nos médias si on n'a
pas envie de jeter les votes dans sa
banlieue dans les niayes femmes eh bien
il va falloir aussi qu'on garantisse le
pluralisme jusqu à chaque fois vous
allez tenir compte de la question de
l'emploi vous naissez ressuscité mais il
ya le transport aérien il a le logement
il y à aussi
beaucoup de mesures qui risquent de
compromettre des implants le voit avec
chaque fois comme un stop pub sur la
boîte à lettres ont détruit un emploi
donc est-ce que vous allez tenir compte
de ça et est-ce qu'à l'arrivée on va
prévoir une loi un peu mais chez michou
mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on assume
encore une fois une ambition écologique
et qui répond à une urgence encore une
fois on n'a plus le choix
c'est ça le préalable on n'a plus
d'autre choix que d'agir
par contre en effet on peut pas agir
sans regarder les conséquences
économiques et sociales que ça pourra
emporter et c'est pour ça que moi face à
ceux qui parlent de décroissance moi
j'assume dire faut parler de
décarbonation donc par exemple quand on
parle de l'aérien et ceux qui vous
disent il faudrait arrêter carrément
quasiment notre industrie aéronautique
alors que c'est un fleuron industriel
fabuleux pour la france est aussi un
enjeu de souveraineté même militaire moi
je pense qu'il faut le réorienter c'est
pour ça par exemple qu'on investit sur
l'hydrogène
parce que se dire que la france pourrait
porter une innovation majeure qui serait
d'avoir le premier avion bas carbone
d'ici 2030
sans ce sera un atout industriel
écologique est un enjeu d'attractivité
aussi pour notre pays dont l'écologie ça
crée aussi de l'emploi par contre on
sait qu'il ya des mesures qui pourraient
avoir des conséquences immédiates en
termes d'emplois et donc c'est ça qu'il
faut réussir à accompagner sinon on
n'embarquera jamais les français sur la
transition écologique une dernière
question rang berger sur la loi
séparatisme menacé le sénat qui entament
l'examen de la loi séparatisme demain le
sénat qui veut remettre la question du
voile dans les débats je rappelle que
vous vous étiez pour l'interdiction du
voile pour les petites filles
proposition était retoquée par votre
majorité et le sénat va donc mettre tout
ça sur la table il veut interdire le
port des signes religieux pour les
sorties scolaires interdire le port des
signes religieux pour les mineurs est
également interdire le burkina et
notamment dans les piscines
est ce que vous dites c'est bien que la
droite sénatoriale remettent ce débat
sur la tap
moi ou c'est j'ai porté ces conditions
là avec jean-baptiste moreau avec un
certain nombre si d'autres membres de la
majorité
si ce sont des propositions qui sont
portées aussi par le sénat temps du
président larcher 10 l inverse il était
contre mon avis ils considéraient qu'il
ne fallait pas par exemple pour ouvrir
cette question ce qui m'a étonné par
exemple que lui président du sénat élu
comme moi dans les yvelines ne souhaite
pas qu'on affronte ou russie cette
réalité donc voyez bien
aussi parfois ces types de propositions
quand parfois il ya du clivage il n'est
pas forcément là où on le pense et je
pense qu'il dépasse justement les partis
politiques encore une étoile est née là
les trois amendements de la part les
amendements en tout cas mieux protéger
les français en particulier les femmes
et les enfants
je pense que ça va dans le bon sens
merci beaucoup merci à steve merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin même
système n'allons pas de ce gîte au club
d'états et à la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés
n'aurait transition zéro carbone des
régions vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales
[Musique]